readers beware the fifth episode of
House of the Dragon changes a key detail
from Fire and Blood and one character
looks all the more Sinister for It
spoilers for both the book and the show
ahead
divisive final season aside it's pretty
obvious that Game of Thrones has become
a permanent Staple in pop culture now it
seems every detail about the characters
confrontations and locations in Author
George R.R Martin's world has become
ingrained in viewers brains from the
names of the targaryens dragons to the
banners of the houses of Westeros
Martin's World Won't soon be forgotten
by fans of the classic series thankfully
these morsels of TV related trivia have
become an enormous help with our return
trip to these Seven Kingdoms in House of
the Dragon fans might struggle after
being thrown into a world so far removed
from the events of Game of Thrones but
the world itself is thankfully familiar
enough to give them the lay of the land
in the case of this week's episode
though one notable Landmark made an
appearance one that has a well-known
history of its own house of the dragon's
fifth episode we light the way features
the short-lived debut of Ria Royce the
estranged wife of Damon Targaryen The
unhappy couple is reunited under the
king's orders after King viserys
commands his brother to return to the
Eerie following a recent Scandal and the
location of their reunion holds
particular significance those that are
only familiar with the TV adaptation of
Game of Thrones will remember that the
first time the veil appeared in the show
was when Catelyn Stark visited her
sister Lisa Tully in the Show's first
season it's also where the Friendship of
Braun and Tyrion began after the former
fought in a trial by combat
you don't fight with honor
he did the location was Notorious for
its impregnable Castle known as the
Eerie marked by steep paths and high
Vantage points The Fortress has a solid
track record of maintaining the home
turf against the enemy that is until
Damon wandered through the land with
nothing but a rock and an attitude yes
in-house of the Dragon demon Targaryen
basically manages to infiltrate and kill
the veil's only Defender his wife Ria
Royce it's an impressive victory for
Damon and more than a little Grizzly but
this scene also features a significant
change from George R.R Martin's original
work in Fire and Blood the book from
which the show is adapted Ria meets a
similar end but it's one that takes much
longer while she does fall from her
horse and cracker head on a rock she
then lives for another nine days
bedridden when she eventually does get
up she collapses an hour later and
finally succumbs to her injuries notably
Damon doesn't kill Ria in the book in
fact he's off fighting a war many miles
away when it happens however the show's
version of events adds another layer of
deception and cunning to Damon's care
character here Rhea is just another
piece to move to how he sees fit by the
end of the episode Damon is already at
work not only in brushing off
accusations regarding Ria's death but
also in making moves on Elena valarian
daughter of Corliss he's certainly not
killing time that's for sure
[Music]